quizfrage wer waren die drei größten
gewinner von 14 monaten corona krise ist
ganz einfach
amazon klopapier und die fdp in umfragen
stabil zweistellig bei 11 12 übrigens
nicht völlig unverdient denn mit ihrer
kritik an unverhältnismäßigen corona
maßnahmen ohne die pandemie zu leugnen
haben die liberalen einen neuen
markenkern gefunden entsprechend
fröhlich ging es zu beim digitalen
fdp-parteitag letztes wochenende
dieser optimismus mit einem schuss
größenwahn
übrigens kam verschiedentlich die frage
auf ob nicht die freien demokraten auch
einen kanzlerkandidaten benennen sollten
ja es kann nicht kurz beantworten nein
andererseits wenn die fdp in thüringen
mit fünf prozent den ministerpräsidenten
stellen kann
warum nicht mit 12% kanzler werden was
war sonst los beim parteitag die fdp
bleibt um es vorsichtig auszudrücken
eher männlich dominiert ziemlich
männlich mit frontmann christian lindner
als vorsitzender wiedergewählt mit 93
prozent also immer noch one-man-show von
wegen sie glauben gar nicht wer da alles
cooles mitmacht michael theurer ist
mister mittelstand nicola beer ist
unsere miss europa wolfgang kubicki mein
väterlicher freund und partner
aha die anderen fdp ventures an
irgendwie coolere helden nahm ab herbst
wollen die liberalen im bund endlich
wieder mitregieren lindner als ansage
der traum jamaica 2.0 oder wenn es
optimal läuft die ampel also fdp mit
grünen und spd
wie realistisch ist das jetzt wo lindner
steuererhöhungen kategorisch ausschließt
ja gar nicht mal so realistisch die
ampel idee ist im grunde schon
geschichte tod denn die fdp will sogar
steuern senken und die wirtschaft um 60
milliarden euro pro jahr entlasten
steuersenkung das klingt dann doch
wieder nach old school fdp und nach
klientel politik falsch die neue fdp
kämpft für alle möglichen gruppen die
junge familie die vom eigenheim träumt
und für die rund freibetrag bei der
grunderwerbsteuer viel bedeutet der
single der seine wohnung liegt auch
werden sie für andere zu groß erscheinen
mag totales tabuthema singles verhungern
in ihrem 300 quadratmeter läuft weil sie
die türen nicht mehr wiederfinden
passiert öfter als man denkt sehr gut
ist sie setzen sich glaubhaft für
bessere bildung ein
nach den letzten monaten wichtiger denn
je schade dagegen ist das harz 4 von der
fdp zwar umbenannt wird in liberale
bürgergeld aber ansonsten fast genauso
bleibt inklusive sanktionen und
wichtigste frage wie das gehen soll den
haushalt nach corona sanieren ohne
schulden und mit weniger steuern den
zaubertrick versteht nicht mal krise ist
wunschpartner cdu
es ist wahrscheinlich eine glaubensfrage
achtung
in diesen tagen breitet sich eine neue
sekte in deutschland aus und findet
immer mehr anhänger die sogenannten
christians zu deutsch christians ihr
spiritueller guru christian verspricht
den haushalt zu sanieren ohne neue
schulden und mit weniger steuern
völlig irre und seine fanatischen jünger
glauben ihm jedes wort wenn ich für uns
erkläre das ist mit den freien
demokraten in regierungsverantwortung
eben keine höhere belastung der
einkommen der beschäftigten geben wird
die christians total verblendete
neoliberale spinner wenn sie bei dir
klingeln
mach nicht auf
jaja tom cruise überlegt schon von
scientology zur fdp zu wechseln
liessmann
und dann hat der parteitag auch noch aus
versehen harte drogen legalisiert es
wirklich war ein neues drogengesetz nach
portugiesischem vorbild hätte den besitz
von zehn tagesdosen harter drogen legal
gemacht na ja dann hat die parteispitze
aber leider gemerkt was da läuft und die
abstimmung wiederholt blöd das war echt
dramatisch deutschlands junkie sitzen
letzten samstag gebannt am smartphone
gucken fdp-parteitag und dann nur
minuten später sind beide vor wut direkt
clean geworden
kopf hoch jungs cannabis legalisierung
bleibt ja im programm
genau wie der klassische fdp klimaschutz
die freien demokraten sehen den
klimawandel als zitat eine der größten
herausforderungen unserer zeit aber der
weg zur klimaneutralität soll den
bürgern möglichst gar nicht belasten
startverzicht fordert die fdp
erfindungsgeist ja lindener redet zum
beispiel ständig von grünem wasserstoff
als werde übermorgen die lösung
tatsächlich bräuchte man heute allein
für den betrieb eines großen stahlwerks
von thyssenkrupp mit grünem wasserstoff
3800 neue windräder nur dafür was wird
garantiert noch erfunden und die fdp hat
jetzt sogar einen klima zink tank
eingerichtet in dem kein geringerer als
olaf schubert an genau den erfindungen
arbeitet die den klimawandel bald
besiegen werden oder auf worauf dürfen
wir uns da freuen
auf jede menge herzlich willkommen hier
aus dem fdp sinkt hier aus dem brunnen
den inner circle und unser motto lautet
innovation statt grüner wohlstands
kastration denn wir hinterfragen die
verbote ja wie oft musste ich als kind
hören ja im dunkeln lesen ist gefährlich
das macht blind
ich habe gefragt warum das ist quatsch
denn wenn ich leise musik höre ich da
von ja auch nicht also verlierer sehen
probleme gewinner finden lösungen
stichwort verkehr ja damals die ersten
einfachen ganz primitiven straßen ja als
sie voll waren was haben die ingenieure
entwickelt richtig die mittelspur und
danach sogar noch die überholspur
pfiffig und so weiter machen heute nicht
einfach dem verbrennen verbieten sondern
moderne infrastruktur entwickeln zum
beispiel alle straßen prinzipiell
einfach backup bauen damit die autos
rollen können
da geht nicht sagt der nörgler warum es
bei den flüssen geht es ja schließlich
auch und das tempolimit ritsch ratsch
ratsch das kehrt der markt ich meine
beim dacia ist ja schon bei 130 mann
alleine schluss und mein porsche ist bei
320 abgeregelt kleiner tipp je schneller
man fährt desto erst die
umweltverschmutzung dabei weil das co2
ja gar nicht mehr hinterherkommt und so
ist es auch beim flugverkehr nicht
einfach verbieten sondern neu denken
eine vernünftige alternative zum
kurzstreckenflug ist der
langstreckenflug mit zwischenhalt ja
also wir globalisieren den nahverkehr da
sie ist quasi regionaljets wird
natürlich nicht ganz klimaneutral gehen
logisch das elektroflugzeug ist noch zu
gefährlich ja ich meine ist oben
plötzlich der akku alle dann kommen die
nicht mehr herunter also die fdp will
gar nichts regulieren das hat doch da
aber mit vernunft und deshalb fordern
wir pro familie in deutschland maximal
einen zweitwagen ich meine wären noch
durch corona schon genug abstriche
machen
wir bauen ja nicht auch noch abstriche
beim lebensstandard und politik muss für
die menschen nachvollziehbar bleiben wir
sind deshalb dafür dass der
meeresspiegel nicht schneller steigen
darf als
die nieten klingt schlüssig und was es
mit steuererhöhungen also umweltschutz
mit steuererhöhungen zu finanzieren ist
kontraproduktiv
wir finanzieren umweltschutz mit
steuersenkungen also man sieht ihr
angestrebte freigabe von drogen zeigt
zumindest bei uns von der fdp und
wirkung und wird jetzt natürlich voll
auf die digitalisierung ja momentan wird
alles digitalisiert warum nicht auch co2
klare forderung co2 scannen und dann
einfach löschen
ich habe schon mal die tasten kombi 22
entfernen wir von der fdp sagen also es
wäre völlig verantwortungslos wenn die
uns auf verdacht und ohne jede grundlage
graue haare wachsen lassen viel bessere
idee hat immer nur wegen des
meeresspiegels wir demonstrieren lassen
sich die kinder endlich mal team
anwachsen problem gelöst und ihr braucht
euch nicht mal zu bedanken oder schubert
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbole bei uns im neuen studio gefunden
illuminati freimaurer staatsführung ist
alles dabei dann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen strippenzieher bekannt
geben dass so viele abonnenten auf
youtube also ich würde mich ran halten